[Musique]
vostok 2018 c'est un grand jeu guerre
trois cent mille soldats 36 milles de
l'inde et des centaines d'hélicoptères
et des navires militaires des foyers
simultanément la russie nous habitué à
ce genre de spectacle
mais cette fois c'est différent cette
simulation de bière est non seulement la
plus importante depuis les années 80
elle se déroule dans l'extrême orient de
la russie avec la participation
officielle de lâcher ces images sont les
premières d'un exercice musclé qui va
durer toute la semaine
bien qu'à les voir aujourd'hui boire de
la vodka et faire des blini lors du
forum économique de vladivostok
il était évident que les présidents
russe et chinois ont préféré insister
sur leurs liens économiques une relation
repose sur la confiance a déclaré le
président poutine signature de contrats
conférence de presse poignée de main
mais pas un mot pas un seul sur ce qui
est pourtant une nouvelle étape de
coopération entre deux pays
traditionnellement adversaires sur le
plan militaire mais pour cet analyste
indépendant qui étudie depuis dix ans le
rapprochement entre la chine et la
russie
le message qu'on voit aujourd'hui pékin
et moscou s'adresse d'abord et avant
tout gouvernement américain qui mène
entre autres depuis des mois une
véritable guerre commerciale contre la
chine
d'ailleurs les menaces du président jean
ping était à peine voilée quand il a
déclaré plus tôt fin lui
l'imprévisibilité du climat géopolitique
rend le partenariat rechigne encore plus
important que jamais et c'est galvanisés
par leur tension respectives avec les
états unis que la kz moscou piqué est en
train de prendre des forces
bien que leur intention soit encore
ambigu ce qui est clair aujourd'hui
c'est que la chine ne considère plus la
russie comme une menace
et c'est en soi un changement majeur
dans l'équilibré des forces sur la
l'international ici thomas reiter escou
radio-canada moscou